ich frage mich warum nicht drei geht
auch in den anderen bereichen und zwar
überall gilt in den gaststätten in den
hotels in den in den klubs in den
diskotheken in den theatern überall denn
es ist doch nicht so dass zweig
gesundheitspolitisch betrachtet einen
vorteil hätte die geimpften sind ja
häufig selbst infektionsträger während
die frisch tagesaktuell getesteten nicht
geimpften eben keine sind die sind
sozusagen sicherer als die geimpften sie
dürfen aber nicht daran teilnehmen das
ist total widersinnig und ich frage mich
was ist der grund dafür warum
differenziert man so ich kann nur eine
erklärung dafür finden es geht darum die
nicht geimpften gerade in der
vorweihnachtszeit so unter druck zu
setzen dass sie nämlich am leben das
spaß macht nicht teilnehmen dürfen dass
sie sich dann doch am ende impfen lassen
weil sie dass sie einfach nicht
aushalten sie können ja in wahrheit
nicht viel mehr als arbeiten zu hause
bleiben und sich zurückziehen wie aig
ist schikane